hello everyone welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are back at day
for round 2 with a very nice game from
the between England and Fabiano Caruana
it's Game three of their match the first
two games between them have been drawn
and this one it's it's just the best I
do think it's the best game of day for
that game between nepo and MV l was also
really crazy with that night sacrifice
on f7 but I don't know I'll let you
decide I prefer this one and when I said
the best game I don't mean the most
precise game or the most well play game
I just mean the most enjoyable one to
watch but you know we'll see what you
guys have to say so without further ado
ding opens wit Knight to f3 against
Bobby Bobby goes for d5 very nice my
favorite replied to the rating we have
g3 g6 and now Bishop to g2 we have
Bishop to g7 and d4 now just
establishing some control in the center
Knight f6 and the C for now basically
transposing into the neo bloomfeld we
have c6 and we have C capture Sundy 5c
captures and Knight to c3 so just the
normal development we have castles and
knights the e5 grabbing hold of that a
very nice outpost on e5 with East six by
Fabi and Bishop to g5 now we have h6 and
Bishop back to f4 and now with maybe
ideas of Queen d2 going after that h6
pawn so first night f2 d7 now suggesting
some trades on e5 we have castles biding
and here far betrays we have Knight
captures Bishop captures Bishop captures
and DD captures and now Knight the c6
just going after the pawn and ding
replies with Queen to d2 he offers this
point for the h6 bone which Fabi defense
and it's interesting both of them played
the position very quickly I think even
has had this position at one point
against Anton horrible in 2017
he was able to win that game with f4 but
here dingos for rook a to d1 and it is a
new move in the position so Fabi
continues would be 6 he wants to get his
Bishop over to this day
you know we have f4 biding and now
Bishop to a6 we have looked the f3 so
now you can move the e pawn and now Rock
the c8 by favi just beginning directed
to the open C file and now g4 preparing
to bust open the position with f5 and
here Fabi finds a very interesting idea
on how to prevent this he plays Queen to
h4 and now ok if I will obviously be met
with Queen characters on g4 not not much
to consider there so first ding the
friends that would work the g3 and here
comes the move that really gets this
game going here Bobby played h5 which is
which is really just interesting and
very dangerous as there for example if
dean captures after Queen captures all
sorts of madness can happen here for
example rook h3 Queen to f5 and now
efore going after the Queen here and
after this is captured not just Knight
captures here and it's just a really
really crazy position where black can
easily go wrong what is much better here
for example a nice tricky variation if
rook here you have to be careful of some
like characters captures and now just
the Knights to g3 attacking the Queen
and winning the knight on c6 so it is
very crazy but dink instead of capturing
you don't want to over calculate you
don't have all that much time plays g5
and he traps fabi's Queen on h4 so ok
that the queen is trapped but there's no
real way to further attack the Queen for
example if you could get this night over
to let's say f3 that would work but
that's easier said than done and you
would require way too many moves and you
don't really have any necessary squares
required to do that Plus also Fabi gets
some moves in so rook F to d8 by Fabi
and now Dean just attacks the Queen rook
h3 queen g4 and now rogue back to g3
father repeats Queen to h4 if you go
here Bishop h3 just traps the Queen so
Bobby has to repeat a Queen h4 he says
ok I'm down with a with a draw a
repetition with the black pieces but
dink plays rook to f1 and what's what's
the idea here first I thought ding was
probably playing planning to go some
like rook F 3 then this rook here and
then this room there maybe
but not really Dean had something else
in mind Bobby went for Knight to the e7
he wants to get his Knight to f5 to
challenge the rook and kick it away from
there
but now Dean plays the most unexpected
move of all he plays f5 and here it just
proves what what kind of what kind of
player doing is this is just complete
madness and he frees the f4 square for
the rook that's the real threat behind
rook to f1 and now rook to f4 will come
with an attack against the Queen so if
you want this is one of the most
complicated positions you're you've ever
seen if you won't pause the video here
and just think about the position you
don't have to look for any moves you can
if you want but it's just a good
position to study you know if you pause
the video for a few a few seconds or
minutes or even more so for those of you
who just you know pondered on the
position and you know just consider lots
of stuff congratulations and doing that
and if you've considered moves like
Knight captures on f5 which is the only
good move for black here then also
congratulations on that and for those
who just want to enjoy the show Bobby
played G captures on f5 and it is a bit
different but to understand why it
doesn't work first we're gonna have to
check out what happens if Knight
captures here point is that after rook
to f4 attacking the Queen
you have d4 this is the crucial idea
because now if you capture the Queen
which is of course what everyone wants
to do the problem is Black has captures
and c3 opens up a double attack on the
Queen and after the Queen moves and now
you have rook to be to further kicking
away the Queen and now just c2 and you
get your Queen back with a winning
position for black so what you would
have to do after d4 you cannot go for
the Queen right away you have to play
you have to move the knight but not to
be one you have to move it to d5 and
this is also very important the knight
from their needs the guarded the rook on
f4 because otherwise if not if for
example you go Knight B 1 let's just
show that if Knight be if Knight B 1
then you have rook to c2 just getting
the Queen away from this rook so now you
either allow the black Queen to escape
which will be much better for black or
you go for trades here and after
captures captures now this night from f5
finally picks up the rock on h4 and now
black is just just better so this this
was the point of the night Knight to f5
move so like I said after this d4 move
you cannot go here you have to go at the
d5 and then then everything just happens
here you get a nice character son g3
rook captures on h4 with night chapters
I need to with check King f2 and now
finally finishing up with each capture
son d5 we get this position where it's a
queen Bishop and rook against two rooks
bishop and night with with a passed pawn
already on d4 so it would be complete
madness however far we played G captures
an f5 pretty much considering the the
exact same motives but that night and f5
is crucial so here Dean played rook
therefore as planned
and now d4 continuing in the same
fashion but now dink has a night to be
one and now rook to c2 no longer works
that hidden resource that we were
talking about as there is no night on f5
because it wants the rook picks up the
Queen you don't have nice to recapture
on h4 so here Fabi had to give up the
Queen for the rook we have Queen
captures on f4 and now just Knight to g6
going after the Queen Queen d2 and now
winning the e5 pawn and okay it's not
over yet being Fabi does have a lot of
pressure going on here with these rooks
controlling a/c and defiled the bishop
slicing over here the night on an
excellent central outpost and there is
the pawn on d4 so rook to a3 immediately
by ding going after the bishop
we have Bishop to b5 and now captures on
a seven-night the g4 by Fabi and now
Knights to a3 getting the night into the
game Bishop character Sonny do here he
wants to give up give up the bishop for
the for the sneaky rook c1 check the
shove the blocks and now Knights the e3
going after the bishop here and now you
have you finally have a passed pawn so
being not interested in giving Fabi
or all of this so instead he goes h3
and now with the knight being challenged
if you will not
nice to III and at the end of this line
doesn't really work so here instead d3
just the defending the bishop here but
now Dean captures the knife with H
captures and now Knight back to be one
will be important as you need to cover
cover the D 2 square
for example if looked the c2 you can go
and Queen to III and the D 2 square is
nicely covered so we have five by five
instead he wants to start pushing his
pawns here and now quinta III we worked
the c5 defending the pawn here and now
Knight the d2 and rook to d4 now so
still not not letting anything slip a
Fabi is continuing to play this game
we have worked the g3 biding now with
the idea of shifting the Queen over to
start attacking the King on the Kings
side and now rook the c1 check we have
King 2 h2 and now f4 we have Queen to h4
and now g3 with check and this is
getting very uncomfortable for Dinks
King King h3 now luckily the best
physical guarding h1 but rook the d6
preventing the Queen from reaching the
h6 square but now adding just goes for
Bishop to d5 he wants to offer the
bishop to to get this Queen h6 check but
then after this it's just over located
irrigate check here and you're getting
checkmated so instead after this Bishop
to d5 move we have looked the east 6 by
far we still hoping that ding will
capture and at least he will get his
rook to h1 check winning the queen but
ding just finishes the game in style
rook captures on f7 with check King
captures and now Queen to h7 with check
King to f8 and now of course it's never
too late to blunder your game again if
you capture rook to h1 will win you the
Queen so hope none of you were
considering capturing the rook here
being played just Queen to f5 check and
it was in this position that far beyond
a corona resign in the game and dink
takes the lead in their match in the 3rd
by winning the third game so here after
the King moves you just pick up the rook
and that's just it black does not have
any counter play after rook each one
check King here and there is nothing
more here as the night covers the f1
squares so there's no Bishop f1 and
just it if you go f3 f3 check you could
continue pushing but then king captures
g2 and there is no way for you to cross
the dark squares having only a light
square bishop so if I saw this and after
Queen to a5 he resigned the game as well
that's that's game three of their match
I do hope you enjoyed it and I do think
it was the best game of the day but it
was a close call between that and the
first game between their Po and mvl so I
do hope you enjoyed that we were
continuing our coverage of the day for
so stay tuned I would like to thank
David chess look mister are alone mush
on a small button and Mark McNair for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thankful for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Magnus invitational
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see soon and have an excellent rest
of your day